the hellenistic are different from the
classical largely in the greater realism
and the motion our title power and
pathos the power has to do with
political power cultural power in the
wake of Alexander and pathos is really
the Greek for lived experience the
Hellenistic is the age where we get
vivid portraiture realistic expressions
and images of people where we can almost
look past their faces very natural forms
and think we see into their souls on
what they're thinking and this is the
really the art of portraiture being born
in this period politically individuals
lost power there were no longer
democracies functioning controlling
their own city life at Athens or Sparta
there were distant rulers the successors
of Alexander the Great and people seemed
to have turned inward in philosophy
others to religion but also in art going
for local honors making statues of
themselves their family members and
those they wish to honor that really
focused on those individual
accomplishments whether it be in
rhetoric in philanthropy in athletics or
some other area we look at bronze in
this case as a medium that contributed
to the artistic developments to a new
styles to new forms of expression new
forms of seeing the human figure and be
it the body or faces in this period
whence alexander conquers all of western
asia
we have a society that's not the similar
to our own global in the sense of pan
mediterranean but you have Greeks Romans
Etruscans people from the ancient Near
East all talking to each other all
moving around traveling and trading many
of the statues in the show twenty
percent of them were found in shipwrecks
and that's not surprising because in
this period there was now an art market
and statues were being transported
overseas this show is in the
extraordinary gathering of about 50
ancient bronze sculptures which is more
than have ever been brought together in
one place in one time in the modern
period and more than we'll probably have
ever again for a long long time
ancient bronzes were valuable and
populated the ancient world in the tens
of thousands but over the centuries most
of them have been melted down and
recycled to reuse their bronze as coins
sword shield buckets or even hinges in
antiquity bronze statues were quite
ubiquitous in public squares and
sanctuaries and places like this and if
you went to places like this you were
surrounded by them so the exhibition
gives an opportunity to maybe capture
some of that
I want visitors to really look closely
and see past the broken edges or the
hollow eyes and reconstruct in their
minds I these complete images of
individuals that are so vivid and speak
to us across time